bonjour ma foi de régis henry je suis
gérant d'insérer le vide
spécialisé dans les automatismes de
portails systèmes de contrôle d'accès
l'entreprise existe 2
bientôt depuis huit ans
et vraiment spécialisés dans la partie
automatisation de portail est
essentiellement sur la partie
résidentielle donc tout ce qui est
immeubles collectifs d'habitation au
delà des automatismes que l'on sait tous
qu'il contrôle d'accès comme sur le
panneau que vous avez derrière moi
interphonie digicode tout ce qui
concerne la périphérie du bâtiment pour
pouvoir accéder à l'intérieur la
sécurité du bâtiment cb métier qui
évoluent avec les technologies actuelles
et les systèmes informatiques appropriés
l'effectif de bip est composé de huit
personnes quatre techniciens une
assistante de direction
ange qui a en charge le sav d'entreprise
une secrétaire dans l'accueil
téléphonique et physique un assistant de
production et qui à lui en charge les
achats de l'entreprise et un commercial
vite pour trouver un technicien ou des
personnes qui ont des qualifications
dans des secteurs de des automatismes
des contrôles d'accès alors les profils
sont généralement tournés vers des bep
et bac pro ou bts
électronique ou électrotechnique
sur le recrutement
nous préférons avoir des gens qualifiés
donc ce sont c'est un métier où il n'ya
pas de formation
appropriée donc la plupart des gens se
forment sur le sur le cas et nous mêmes
pour monde et les techniciens à
notre spécificité des personnes qui ont
déjà de l'expérience et un savoir faire
dans ce domaine
ont déjà
un grand avantage le type de contrat que
nous proposons
et plus
un contrat en cdd avec une
une évolution
dans la mesure où notre spécificité est
quand même
et quand même assez particulière les
automatismes le contrôle d'accès et
il termine en règle générale sur un
contrat à durée indéterminée
le technicien automatismes et contrôle
d'accès doit
maîtriser les connaissances élémentaires
en électricité et en électrotechnique
concevoir et mettre en place des
systèmes complexes
réaliser un diagnostic des causes de
défaillance
faire preuve d'un bon contact clientèle
un petit conseil pour les personnes
intéressées
j'ai reçu une demande here
c'était très bien formulé la personne a
pris soin de faire un cv et une demande
qui est vraiment très attrayante donc je
vais vraiment prendre note de cette
demande et rappeler cette personne qui
déjà
à beaucoup de choses intéressantes a à
me dire farcissez vais donc n'hésitez
pas à pour vous faire valoir vos
compétences à mettre le maximum dans ce
petit papier qui est quand même votre
image
bonjour je m'appelle c'est vrai qu'à m
j'ai 32 ans j'habite à lamentin je
recherche un emploi de serveuse sur
saint denis j'ai passé le bp styliste en
2000 à duparc à sainte-marie en 2011
j'ai fait le bafa et je m'occupe
toujours des enfants aujourd'hui
actuellement je travaille avec les
enfants dans une école élémentaire de la
montagne je fais de l'animation sportif
manuels j'ai fait un contrat de deux ans
aussi dans un restaurant le pékinois à
saint denis je suis rigoureuse
autonome
très souriant
très attentif avec les autres et je suis
très motivé pour ce métier comme je
voulais dit je suis très motivé
n'hésitez pas à me contacter contactez
nous sur notre page facebook
www.facebook.com slash 9 7 4 tv ou par
téléphone 02 100 62 92 37 60
de 7 4 cv autre émission au service de
l'emploi à la réunion